and you said your dating life what is
your dating life like right now I mean I
am dating I am dating someone one
specific person not just on Ryan not
just on Ryan whatever I am dating
someone okay Savannah Chrisley is making
time for romance while raising her
younger siblings there's just things in
your life that you need to make a
priority and when you notice that you're
not okay then you have hopefully the
tools to fix it the 25 year old gained
custody of 16 year old Grayson and 10
year old Chloe who's gonna go on a walk
with Mom and me I'm not yeah no I'm not
either me either as their parents
started serving their combined 19-year
prison sentence for tax fraud there's a
10 year old there's a 16 year old so now
like we've got to get through this in a
healthy manner sure and it's hard but
Savannah's not letting her situation
hold back any romance on Caitlin
bristow's off the vine podcast the
reality star reveals she's got a new boo
but isn't quite ready to share him with
the world right now I'm like okay I kind
of want to keep it like in a safe place
yeah until you know for sure like okay
is this what is this gonna turn into and
people are just hateful it's so hateful
people are hateful they're gonna say
they're always gonna compare to the last
person you were with I'm just like you
know what maybe I'm not quite ready
right to let you in on that seems like
Savannah's referencing her ex-fiance
Nick cardelis will you marry me yes yes
the two split in 2020 after three years
together we went through so much
together and he taught me a lot of
things there was just so much growing
that we both did and so many things that
we learned from each other that were
both extremely grateful for and we still
talk we still you know we're on good
terms and I'd like to say no decision is
ever permanent so if we're meant to be
together we'll be and if not God has
someone else better suited for each of
us well Savannah's clearly moved on and
her new man is already spending time
with the Chrisley crew have Grayson and
Chloe met yeah yeah yeah
and too because I'm like you know what
it's package deal yeah the Chrisley
Knows Best star says she's been very
transparent that it's all or nothing now
I see like single moms like how how do
you do it like you just and so then I'm
like you know it's just package deal
yeah you want to go to dinner these two
are coming along I love it because I
love of that again no games this is how
it is and if you want to be part of this
you have to know what you're getting
into this is what you're getting into
guess what there's two kids my parents
aren't in the greatest place in the
world right now like you know it all 110
transparency if you're in you're in if
you're out you're out
foreign